[Music]
is this the future of gaming or this or
neither of all the new exciting
technological advances in the last few
years that have attempted to establish a
foothold in the world of video games
virtual reality has truly had the most
success sorry
motion control well BAM there it is but
what about augmented reality
enter Microsoft with hololens the
computer tech giant made arguably the
most exciting reveals since the first
Xbox recently by unveiling this little
device
now while this holographic computer as
the company are calling it is a
standalone device not targeted at any
one application this clip of 3d
Minecraft suddenly appearing in a living
room certainly got a lot of people
excited and talking about gaming
applications of hololens GameSpot sister
site C Netcom even argue that gaming is
the number one most exciting potential
use of this technology so how does
hololens work what kind of new gaming
experiences could it offer and how does
it compare to the gaming promised of its
cousin virtual reality Facebook's oculus
rift Sony's project Morpheus and all
other VR tech have one main goal to
create the feeling of presence this is
the sensation of actually being in a
place which feels real in other words
filling the wearer's brain into
believing as much as possible that they
are really in the place that they see
augmented reality devices on the other
hand like hololens are all about adding
things on top of existing reality
allowing the user to manipulate digital
holographic objects in a real physical
space the promo movie for hololens gave
a glimpse of the kind of uses Microsoft
has in mind from constructing an object
to be later 3d printed modeling a
motorcycle design prototype in real-time
3d to walking on the Martian surface
all pretty cool but how does this thing
actually work well it's got transparent
lenses so you can see the world of Ranji
as well as the holographic images the
goggles will track your movements watch
your gaze and transform what you
by blasting lights in your eyes don't
worry doesn't actually heart also
because the device tracks where you are
you can use hand gestures like the
midair click we see in the demo here to
manipulate the holographic objects also
thanks to sensors in the unit it can
spatially map your environment allowing
Holograms to be placed on actual
surfaces in the real world plus your
voice can be used to issue commands as
well so how does this AR device compared
with its VR cousins well first of all
it's untethered it doesn't need to be
attached to a separate computer because
it contains its own CPU GPU and H PE or
holographic processing units unlike
oculus and Morpheus this gives the user
complete freedom of movement around the
environment so when it comes down to
their respective gaming applications I
think it's really all about the type of
experience you're after
while VR is really what you will need if
you want to be fully immersed in a
fantasy world
AR also throws up some really cool
possibilities of its own imagine if you
can building whole worlds out of blocks
right there in your living room alright
fine but this would have unlimited pcs
plus you'd never have to fear the
consequences of stepping on straight
locks you could also play hearthstone on
your kitchen table which would be sweet
in fact once resolution is good enough
any surface in your whole house can be
transformed into a gaming display but
that would be a game changer while
Microsoft aren't talking specifics at
this point head of Xbox Phil Spencer did
comment that they're thinking hard about
specific scenarios with the Xbox with
things like content streaming and using
it as a display for Xbox ultimately
though I think with VR and AR we're
looking at two sides of a rapidly
converging pi is that saying there is no
my point is though that in a few years
time we're only gonna want to wear one
pair of silly glasses and there's no
reason why both VR and AR can't perform
the job of the other hololens is already
creating pixels in your vision it just
needs to create a graphic that
completely covers your field of view and
there we have an immersive reality and
ask for VR just take a couple of cameras
on your headset and you're ready for a
basic AR experience so what do you make
VR and AR can you think of any cool
ideas for how hololens could improve
gaming or do you think some other piece
of technology will have a much bigger
impact on the future of video games let
me know in the comments down below or of
course you can send me a tweet to add
cam Fras Rob see you soon
[Music]